une femme française est à l'honneur aux
états unis christine lagarde vient
d'être nommée présidente du cabinet
américain d'avocats le plus important du
pays et le deuxième au monde c'est la
première fois qu'une telle société de
juristes est présidé par une femme 43
ans christine lagarde dirigera un groupe
de 2400 avocats répartis dans 60 bureaux
et 35 pays dominique derda et de leur
père un nom rencontrer c'est un univers
d'hommes ou du moins ça l'était un monde
de verre et de béton dans lequel
longtemps aux étages élevés du pouvoir
les femmes n'ont fait que de la
figuration ou ne furent cantonner qu'à
des tâches subalternes mais c'est un
monde qui bouge et la nomination à la
tête du plus grand cabinet juridique
américain d'une femme jeune et étrangère
de surcroît est une petite révolution
à 43 ans la française christine lagarde
est la nouvelle présidente directrice
générale de baker & mckenzie
elle règne désormais pour 3 ans sur une
multinationale de 2400 avocats répartis
dans 35 bureaux et 60 pays
c'est un monde dans lequel les
compétences prime sur les a priori et si
les gens sont à la mesure des défis qui
leur sont posés sur le plan
professionnel
sept principes de fonctionnement sont en
train de disparaître je crois qu'on
parle d'un d'un vieux monde le monde
demande de dommages l'espère fera fi de
ces deux matches à en croire les hommes
qui travaillent à ses côtés son élection
au poste de pdg fut une formalité cela
fait 18 ans que christine lagarde a
rejoint le groupe à son siège parisien
12 ans qu'elle est partenaire associé de
baker mckenzie ce qui à l'époque déjà
faisait pour une femme figure
d'exception d'habitude il y a toujours
de longs débats au sein du conseil pour
déterminer qui sera le prochain
président mais cette fois je peux vous
affirmer que dès le départ elle a fait
l'unanimité parmi nous adolescente
christine lagarde rêvait déjà de
parcourir la planète
son métier le savez ne pouvait se
limiter aux frontières de l'hexagone la
voici au sommet d'un empire qui a dégagé
l'an dernier près de 800 millions de
dollars de bénéfices des premières
choses que vous ayez envie de faire ses
repas le bureau changer le mobilier et
mettre votre nom sur la pop
oui apporter un grand un grand coup de
fraîcheur et 1
et
fête de la lumière c'est important pour
moi je crois que c'est important pour
pour tous les avocats de la firme de
sentir la lumière est là et le mouvement
en avant sportive christine lagarde fut
membre jadis de l'équipe de france de
natation synchronisée une école de
résistance de persévérance et d'énergie
le secret peut-être de sa spectaculaire
ascension